this is from the daily wire it says fans
of the marvel of uh the marvel films are
divided about a chemotherapy scene in
the new hit
film thor love and thunder with some
clamoring for a trigger warning and
others deriding the protesters for their
squeamishness
uh thor love and thunder premiered on
july 8th it features a scene in which
actress natalie portman who plays thor's
love interest scientist jane foster
undergoes chemotherapy treatment for
stage four cancer
one fan wrote on social media no
spoilers but thor love and thunder
should have a trigger warning for
graphic depictions of cancer and the
fact that we didn't know going in is
atrocious
the fan concluded cancer is way too
common of a trigger and when they show
it that graphically with that much
imagery and dwelling on it and talking
about it that much you need to be warned
especially for a marvel movie which
people go to for escapism and shouldn't
have to read the comics
um so i guess she got cancer in the
comics and that's why they have i don't
know and then there are other fans
chiming in saying this is terrible
people have ptsd from it
look
this is actually interesting because on
one hand i i you know what i sort of
agree
i i sort of agree with with the
criticism
that it's gratuitous in a way to put a
cancer storyline into the middle of one
of these dumb movies into the middle of
thor
you know it's it is it is a little bit
actually gratuitous um and the reason is
that these aren't real movies they're
just toy commercials and brand awareness
campaigns and in that context cancer
seems like a kind of inappropriate
subject matter and sort of exploitative
now i don't think there should be a
trigger warning because i just disagree
in principle trigger warnings but it is
a cheap and kind of easy way to create
an emotional moment
without doing the work as the left likes
to say you haven't done the work so it's
lazy
you don't have to
uh do you know
write a good script you don't have to
make people emotionally invested in the
scene you don't have to worry about good
acting all you have to do is just have a
character with cancer and and that's
good enough it's kind of like using a
nazi as your bad guy which i think these
marvel movies also do quite a bit
because if you do that
it's easy you don't have to actually
convince the audience through good
writing and good acting to hate the bad
guy he's a nazi he's got all that
baggage with him all the work is done
just slap a you know slap a um
you know a nazi symbol on him and you're
good to go you know given recent scotus
wins it feels like the pendulum may be
swinging back to a time when the nuclear
family was situated at the center of
american life
where real conversation learning and
growth began at home with your family
gathered around the dinner table in
president ronald reagan's farewell
address he said all great change in
america begins around the dinner table
he could have been more right about that
bring your family to the dinner table
with good ranchers goodranchers cares
deeply about providing families with
high quality meat at a reasonable price
their mission is to bring people to the
table making those shared moments with
your loved ones easy accessible and
delicious
good rancher ships 100 american meat
born raised and harvested in the u.s
right to your door plus when you
subscribe your price is locked in for
the for the life of the subscription you
have to worry about inflation or
anything there so you have that
stability as well good ranchers not only
supports american agriculture they're
also big fans of the daily wire they
sponsor all of our shows and uh that's
all the more reason to support them so
make sure you check them out use my code
matt for 30 off plus free shipping on
your order take advantage of this offer
today you don't want to miss it invest
in time share with your family you're
going to buy meat anyway we all are
going to buy meat unless you're one of
those
weird vegetarians make sure you buy
great meat from folks who support all
that we do here go to goodranchers.com
matt to start bringing people back to
the table and eating seriously delicious
food at the same time and if you've
already bought from goodrancher show me
what you're making post a photo of your
meal and tag me and my friends at
goodrancher so that they can see it too
on one hand i agree on the other hand
trigger warnings as a concept are
incredibly stupid
um so it just goes to show though
that martin scorsese was correct when he
said that marvel movies aren't cinema
they're more like theme parks
and in cinema you know the audience
would never be upset or offended because
something happened they didn't expect
like you that's what you want if you
actually are a film fan and you want to
go watch a movie if you want to partake
in the art of cinema and and witness it
then you don't want to know every beat
ahead of time you want things to happen
that you don't expect that's why you're
there that's part of the magic of cinema
but superhero fans um
that's not what they're in it for they
want the same thing over and over again
very much like children they just want
the same thing
over and over again they don't want
anything surprising anything different
they just want a theme park ride where
you see the track ahead of time and
you've been on it before
and you know where all the dips and
dives and everything are gonna be
so i guess in that way it's like an
actual theme park ride
if they tried to you know if you were on
a theme park right there was a a cancer
theme park ride we would all agree
that's highly inappropriate
so
in a way
i can actually see where they're coming
from
this was my attempt to sympathize with
marvel
while at the same time consulting which
is the only way i can do it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts
you